thank you
okay so uh we have some
english speakers here and most of the
people
are spanish speakers
in english so we're going to talk in
spanish
but we're going to repeat the main
points on english
we're two people here and while one
people talk
the other one will go through the
tables and help you if you need help if
you only speak english i
you don't understand any point the the
materials are in english and we can help
you in english so no problem
porn
if you can't do anything we can help
okay so
come
any of you doesn't have anaconda
installed
right now again
raise your hand please because kiko will
lend you some usb drives
we will start downloading our materials
they are very easy to find okay you know
github
right everybody knows github so we can
just um
search the pi data madrid uh repository
okay repository
the wi-fi okay the data for the wi-fi is
this one okay
if you have any problems uh
the wi-hi the wi-fi is here
uh
okay so we will start downloading the
materials if you don't have already
downloaded because we uploaded them
tonight so you
just search google for github if you
don't know what git copy is
everybody has the materials at the
workshops the materials are
also in the okay so we can download it
or we can just copy from the pen drives
so if you don't feel confident about
downloading them
just ask for pen drive
um
uh our workshop material are here
in the conference inf repository
so we just will download it
is here the button
download zip okay and you just
have to download it and
unzip them anywhere and it will look
like
this
okay so we download it
we unzip it and it will look like
it will look like this
uh
so i don't know if you know how to
launch the jupiter notebook
i will just teach you because it's very
easy
here in this folder
in windows we will press
shift key with a right button and
open the the terminal in windows is like
open command line or something like that
it's easy
okay and we will just launch it by
writing
okay anybody have problems doing this
okay if you have any problem just raise
your hand please and we will help you
okay but
who hasn't this already
in okay raise your hand please
okay
okay keep keep your hand raised please
while we help you and i will just start
we will work here with the empty
notebook
okay
and the first thing we have to do
a
um if you have downloaded you have to
trust it
in order to have like a nice
uh look
okay
hello
um
okay
okay how many of you did know conda or
anaconda before
coming here cuantos conoces anaconda
vale unos cuantos cuantos no conocias
anaconda secrecios cuento poco de quebec
anaconda
you have all the texts in the materials
are in english
if you don't follow the explanations
okay uh
is
me
is
anybody has lose the thread
are everybody with me yes okay so
alex
now alex will talk and i will help you
okay
notebook
is
yes
a
elements
size
b
is
elements
columns
foreign
is
a
a
any question in english english speakers
are you lost completely lost
yes you are if we continue in span
in english does anyone have a problem
with that okay because i don't want to
get people
lost here okay sorry
okay if anyone is going this way
one by one
no don't go that way and
i guess some people is trying to perform
this operation in a loop
in a for loop with two for loops okay
that's not bad but the performance won't
be that good
we should do something like using the
slicing we've seen before
so if i want to take first the first row
skip the second one take the third one
i will be doing something like from the
first one
to the last one with step two
and then if you see the pattern here
i want to put a one another one here
another one here
so starting from the third from the
second element
which is index one i'll go to the last
one
and i will skip one each time
if i print my chessboard right here
yeah i'm doing it the right way
so the only thing i have to do is the
same
for the rest of the rows
board okay i started in the first one
last time so now i will start with the
second one i will go to the last one
i will skip one every time and i will do
the same with the columns but starting
with the first one
to the last one skipping one every time
and
there i have my chessboard
okay any question until this point
uh we don't have much time but it would
be interesting to compare the
performance of this operation
against the for loop in this case it's
not a very big array and
you're not going to suffer from
performance problems
but maybe if you go to larger arrays
you will see that clearly once we are
here another
interesting thing we want to do in
science is to plot things
so which is the right library if i want
to do a 2d
simple plot matplotlib
matplotlib matplotlib can also
plot 3d plots but maybe if you want to
do complicated things it's not the right
tool and you need to change this is one
of the cases
advantages it is simple if you know
matlab
as many people in science world and as
i've seen you do
it's really really similar the first
thing we have to do with the library
as always in python is to import it
we will import this import a macbook
live this way
from mathclub leave dot
pi plot
oh sorry not for from
import
as plt
plt okay if you have matplotlib
installed
you should have no problems if you don't
have it you will discover it now
so now that i have my chessboard maybe i
want to
visualize it i can do this with the
function much so
much soap and
one useful thing from the notebook
what happens if i want to see the help
of a function
i do shift tab and i will see this
okay that's good but i want more shift
tab
twice and now i have the whole help here
okay so if i don't remember how this
function works
i see i pass an argument a here
which i guess it's my array it says
board
okay nothing happens what's the problem
normally matplotlib sorry there normally
matplotlib will open a new window with
the plot
what we want to do now and many times
when using the notebook is to get the
plot
right in the notebook so i will use this
command
which is a command for the notebook to
take into account
which says matplotlib inline
inline
now i see my chessboard
there's an option color map that i can
use to change the colors and get a
regular chessboard with
white and black but we'll go into that
later with other functions
i'm going to lose i'm not going to lose
any time there any questions until this
point
so this is okay but normally you don't
want to plot chessboards
normally we want to plot functions so
the first thing
i will do is to create the x value
with a line space in space
i will go from 1 to 10 and i will
use let's say 200 values
and which function i guess the thing
below
was a sign so i will use the sign
of x right
okay maybe i can do this and also
this and this and now much better
okay so just one thing
um some questions people normally ask us
when we are explaining these kind of
things is why do i need to use
a numpy function for
computing the sign of these x why not
the one from the math module in in
python which many people i guess has
used
have used before the answer is it
doesn't work
the sign function in the mind the
mathematics model of python
it's you need to pass it a value just
one value
load the whole array you will need to
perform a loop
or whatever in order to compute all the
values so this
numpy sign is really optimized for arise
and it will compute the loop
for you in compiled language below
so um we have many other mathematical
functions we'll see some of them but
you can find the exponentials
okay logarithms and a lot of them
so let's plot our sign
i will do vlt plot
and now what do i want to plot if i
don't remember how this works
i have some examples here so i will say
x y and then i have my sign
if you are used to matlab again and it's
not that i want to promote matlab i want
to promote
python but this is easy for you to
change
if you want you will be used to do
things like
plot it in red and use
this kind of okay so you have that
function there
i was going to plot another function
here but i guess it's something easy and
i'm going i'm not going to lose
any time on this because
we are running out of time so i was
telling you that we can
perform really optimized operations here
and sometimes not only computing design
but also linear algebra operations
i guess i have my two-dimensional array
over here
okay it's not the nicest one
but what happens if i want to get the
transpose of this array
i simply do this
okay this is a transpose matrix
multiplication okay how many of you are
running
python 3.4
34 this won't work for you
i will explain the the solution
and okay matrix multiplication to the
mri
uh and i've been really complicated
since python 35 this is the
binary operator for matrix
multiplication
and for me it's something that is really
helpful
for those of you that this is not
working
i will show you how it used to be before
it was like 2d mri
dot
okay this is not really a problem but if
you
want to multiply three arise if you are
doing a kalman filter or
some other algorithm using a lot of
matrix matrix multiplications matrices
inversions
you will finally have
lines of code for the equations
splitting in three four five lines for
just one
operation in this way we can read it
as it is okay at is not like much of
multiplication but
it helps what happens if i want to
multiply a matrix by a vector
i guess i have one dimensional right
here but
okay it is not valid
x equals
my one dimension i'll array before and
let's get only
three elements i have four elements in
the matrix so i i will
gather four elements of the array
these are the first four elements of
that array
okay zero one two three and the fourth
element
i don't get it it's how it works and now
to the mri at
one demo right okay it's not one dimmer
right it's x
and now it works some of you those of
you who have been using matlab
will be asking yourselves
okay but it is x a column array
or is it a row array how do i know the
answer is
it's just an array one dimensional it's
not a column it's not a row it's an
array
so when i'm performing this operation
the binary operator will manage to
know how to do the multiplication if i
do the opposite now
and do pre-multiplication obviously i
will need a row array instead of a
column right
two-dimensional right but it will manage
again the problem is that i don't get
the dimensions of this
it's just an array again i have to
manage myself to convert this
into a volume vector if it's what i need
a difference between a fun vector
no python is not making that difference
never that's only in matlab for those
using matlab
okay if you want to use raw
row vectors or column vectors the option
is to define a two dimensional array
let's say you want a column vector you
define up an array
two-dimensional with let's say five
columns
five rows and just one column so you get
stuff
yeah is that what matlab does but it's a
little bit tricky
sometimes i mean it's not a
straightforward okay
let's say i want the inverse and i want
to spend
much more time here i can find this
function in
numpy linear algebra operations
just line out
inverse
singular i don't know how i manage but
every time i
try this i get with a singular matrix
okay that's good because we see
that it will tell us about uh
let's create one
okay
five six
seven
and now zero
one minus three
oh uh
okay now it's working and i get the
inverse here
another thing i could be interested and
i will stop with
linear algebra right now are
eigenvectors and eigenvalues
so numpy linear algebra
a will provide me with the
answer for this two dimensional array
okay here i have the eigenvalues and
here
if i'm not wrong every column is an
eigenvector
for that eighteen value
okay any question until this point
so just come
all right but this is a pie data
it's a conference about data so let's
see how we can apply this
to data
as you know we have a problem with
pollution here in madrid and
we are a little bit worried with that
and now
the city hall is providing us with the
data
i have to say it's not really friendly
the way
they do that but okay it's something
they are improving and
i get i guess that if we put a little
bit of pressure on them
we'll get more i will load some data
that you have in the repository it's
under folder data
and if i do this
okay one more thing about the notebook
this is a linux command
if i put this clammation mark here
i will execute command line
uh sorry command line um
yeah okay so if i do head
i will see the first 10 lines of the of
the data file
i want to use if you are on windows i
guess this thing here
works you just have to uncomment it and
run it
probably it won't work because i didn't
try it but
okay this is the data file we have
it corresponds to this
weather station okay and we have this
data
date time uh co
no2 all three concentrations and we have
the units also
so how do we load this data from a csv
file
into a numpy array
we'll use numpy gem from txt
function and then again if i don't know
how this works
i can get some help here the first thing
i will specify
is the file name file name
which is with the root data
and then okay the name was
barrio del pilar okay if i
complete with the tab i get some help
and i won the one from
2016 first and we will compare after
this from 2016 corresponds to the
last week of march so it's pretty active
data
if i run this just like this okay
value error i don't get anything
what's the problem as i was telling you
numpy arrives are um
the data type of the array has to be the
same for the whole array so what's
happening here i have a date
and i have some floating points here i
have some strings
there so i will have to help
this function a little bit the first
thing i'll do is to escape
the header which let's see if i see it
here
was skip header skip header the first
three lines
i will also specify the separator
because i guess it's
expecting a comma not a semicolon
and i will also
use only some of the columns
with the option use calls
calls okay i'm out of the screen
so i will just continue in this line
i will say i will tell it i want not the
first one
okay not the second one which is the
time
i want the third one the fourth one and
the fifth one
so i have to subtract one because it's
starting zero
this would be zero one so
sorry zero one two three four
two three and four
okay i guess i invented this
it's daily miter deli miter not
separator
but it seems it works
i will print it
there i have it okay
does everyone have the data loaded into
the array
so what we are doing here okay
let's see what happens if i want for
example the mean
numpy mean of data
2016.
yep
i will make it easier for you
okay remember skip header the first
three lines
delimiter is a semicolon and then use
calls
okay if we are okay with this we
continue
let's see we want to see the the mean of
the whole
data right just as the first approach
okay i was writing and i didn't complete
it
so not a number what's happening here
some of the values when it read it from
the csv file
was not a number in numpy if you add and
not a number if you multiply by and not
a number
it will give you not a number so what
can we do with this
first option numpy none mean
this function will skip not the numbers
won't
take them into account and just compute
them in
second approach which is a little bit
more sophisticated
than the one we'll use
is to mask the array i will
do this first and explain you explain
you after
numpy the module to mask arise
ma mask
and i have a lot of options here the one
i'm looking for is
mars invalid
what will this function do masks can
arrive where invalid
values occur nones or imps
that's what we want so if we do this
data 2016 and load this
here
data 2016.
we have now must arrive what does this
mean
okay let's see you see this big array of
false false false false false
when you mask and arrive you get two
arrives the original one with the data
and then a boolean array the boolean
array
has the same shape as the data and will
contain a false
if the data is okay is not masked and
will contain a true
for nouns imps and all that invalid
values
so what does what what is the advantage
of this do i have to manage with the
to arise not at all not at all
numpy will do that inside for me
okay so now that i masked the array
i can use mean again
and it will provide me with the right
result
this is sometimes really useful you can
maskarize with many many
different criteria
and at some point if you are using numpy
you will need
this for sure okay but this is not
really
useful i mean i'm getting the mean of
the whole array
the units are different the
pollution data is different
i mean i want the mean of every column
every column
so if i go with numpy mean
data and i
specify axis
zero okay
i cannot see the whole thing here but i
get the mean of the first
column the mean of the second column the
mean of the third column
if i do axis one i would get the mean of
the first row
then the second row the other row okay
this is how it works
so okay this thing i was going to do
that
before and now what we will do is to
compare this data
with data from 2015 december
i guess you can remember this if you
live in madrid
uh i have
okay you were using your car
that day do you remember this for sure
so what we will do is to load this data
and as it is really similar
from the it's the same kind of file i
will just copy this
okay
and of course i have to change the name
of the file
if i come here let's say
2015
there i have the data of course i will
mask the invalid values
okay so
let's go with some plots
plt plot
if i don't specify the x values
it will by default give me an arranged
array
with 0 1 two three each of the
numbers will correspond to a day in the
file so i will use this option
and i want to pla to plot data from 2015
first okay i want
all the rows because i want to plot data
every day
and i want only no2 which
if i'm not wrong was the first column
so we are using slicing as we
so before this is the data
now i just have to copy this line
and plot data from 2016
but now i don't know which one is uh
for 2015. so i will use
lavell equals 2015.
and 2016.
i will also plot a legend
okay there we have it
so what's the max value for this
it's 200 micrograms
where so
what if we plot an 8
lines with y value
from x min to x max so y
value will be 200 from 0
to 200 let's say
okay
maybe it's
sorry
line style and i guess
this will work
unknown property line style
okay line styles
okay line styles with s in this function
if we do the same in plots
the correct argument is line styles also
but i can use
ls sorry
okay so that's what happened uh in
madrid
the december 22nd and the 23rd
the co2 level was above the maximum
value allowed
and we went with this story
that you can read here by the way what
i'm doing here is another thing
another useful thing you can do in
notebooks is just to
insert a new url
okay this is html code
and you just execute it and
okay it doesn't work if you don't
okay it didn't like that space there
so we have it here now this is
disturbing me so i can do
double click and it will just hide
okay uh we are running a little bit out
of time
so i will skip the these two examples
here
i was doing more or less the same with
some other values of c
o and also so on and i was computing the
moving average because the criteria
was the maximum of eight hours
moving average okay so we won't do that
here
now i will skip this it's not really
interesting for the plots
and the values were kind of normal
okay
what's what's next the next package you
will
use for sure if you are using scientific
calculations is
scipy scipy is divided into some other
packages
we have linear linear algebra it
contains
more functions than non-pi linear
algebra packets which we were using
before we also have some functions for
statistics
for integration optimization
interpolation
fourier transforms okay signal analysis
i have to say this one if you come from
matlab it's not as
powerful as small lab signal analysis
tools
but okay they're working on it so
we'll use now some data
temperature data from the spanish
ministry of agriculture
the data is from sorry
from this station here in san fernando
de nares okay
it's just because they are worried about
where they have
agriculture not inside the cities so the
data is there
and okay i have to say that this data is
a little bit
tricked i mean i manipulated it a little
bit i
removed the numbers there were missing
values for some days
which i just put the last valid
value because uh i want to use numpy
here and then your question is okay but
what if i want to use the real data
real data has missing values have not
numbers then
kiko after we'll show you how to do that
in pandas which is the the right
package for that kind of tasks
so okay let's let's say our data is okay
and this is the file we will be loading
it's also in the data folder we will
also use
gen numpy
then from txt okay
file name which is uh
with the path data um
okay there i have it uh
daily miter uh was
so okay if i go here
daily miter it's also a semicolon
and i think i wanted to skip
something okay sorry for this
okay oh i want to move back
here sorry
okay i'm back
okay and let's see what we have right
now
okay we have our data why are not doing
a skip rows
skip header here by default jim from txt
will skip
lines starting with uh slash
no not slash hash okay
hashtag okay so we have our temperature
data
and we'll import the statistics
functions from
cpy so import
cpy stats
as st
and we have some fancy functions that we
can use here
let's say st
describe that you will use
also in pandas later
okay we have the number of observations
we have min and max values
uh we have the mean we have covariance
we have some other functions
if we want just one of them specifically
we can also use not mean because mean is
in
numpy there was there were some
duplicates and now they are moving
the simple ones to numpy stats
and the more fancy ones to sify
so numpy mean okay we have done this
before
this is for the whole array ah but i
didn't explain you anything about this
data
what is this data we have
for each day of the year since 2004
to 2015 the mean
temperature value for that day the max
temperature value for that day
and the mean temperature value for that
day and you may be asking which day
okay the first one is january the the
1st
of june of 2004 then i will get
365 values and i will have january the
1st
of 2005. it will go like that
also for people wondering okay what we
what happens with
leap gr on february 29th in 2004. i also
removed that
okay i was being a little bit tricky i
told you before
but i just wanted to use numpy not going
to pandas
so as i told you the first
column was the mean temperature value so
if i want
the mean of the mean temperature value i
will do something
like this why not for every day
the first column okay
if i want the mean of the max values
or if i want the mean of the mean values
okay so i will go a little bit faster
here
uh some more fancy functions about
sci-fi statistics
let us to deal with percentages i can
know the person till fast score
for example let's say i want i will work
with
temp data every day
only the mean value
and i want the percentile
of the score uh
let's say the mean value zero
well sorry i guess this is just
this is score the score
ah there i have it
okay this is the percentile of a
zero degrees volume
i can also go with a score
of a score at percentile which will do
the inverse of this
okay so
right now i have my data in a two
dimensional array as i told you
a lot of rows and one gr
after the other maybe
what is more useful for us is to change
the shape with a reshape as i introduced
you before
into a three dimensional right let's say
that we have
every day of the first year here we have
the mean
we have the max we have the mean and we
have 2004 the first one 2005
2006. you see what i mean right
so the first thing i'll do is to make an
empty array
of zeros which has 365 rows one for each
day
the number of uh different values i want
to
store and then the number of years from
2004
to 2015 i have
11 plus one so 12.
i can see if everything went okay
there i have my right and
what i will do here is to load the data
from the old array
into the temp data to arrive i will do
this with a for loop
four in range
as i told you before i have 12 years so
i will perform
one loop step for every year
and in temp data true i will store
the values for every day of that year
for every different value and
i will be in the first for 2004 in the
second for 2009
and five i will load my data from temp
data
and here i will go from
to ee plus one
364. okay
all the data stored
and that's all because this is a
two-dimensional array
okay if i'm not wrong this would work
and now what i have is stem data two
and if i want to see only the mean
values i will get just the first
column for the first 10 days of the year
for the first year which was 2004.
this is what i get okay i'm wrong
here it's the first 10 days
all the values okay
and this is working right now as you see
okay this is working but it's not really
comfortable
uh i have to remember that 2004 is the
zero index
and okay this is not the right way to do
this but
it will be great for us in order to use
these functions and to use numpy
and as i've said many times before with
pandas this will be much easier
so let's calculate the mean
of the means that we did before
numpy mean
of data
temp data sorry
then data two okay
i want every day i want
only the first column
and i will i want every year
this is returning me a two dimensional
array and i will go along the second
axis
of that array which is the grs in order
to compute the mean of the mean
temperature every day
let's see if this is okay before
continuing
okay there we have it
so now i will do something similar for
the max
okay max max is equal
numpy max then data two
every day there's the first column
every year along the years
and the mean of the mean
with number mean
then data to
axis equal one
i have everything there i'll give you
some time
to copy
when i explain you that in matplotlib we
also have some different styles
if you want to see all the different
styles available you have
to do plt style available and then we
have a list
one the one that i like
maybe you don't agree with me
it's gg plot
so i will use it just like this
and i want to reproduce
this figure here this is the max
of the maximum value for
different days of the year this would be
january the 1st this will be
the december the 31st and this is the
mean of the means
so how do i do this the first one it's
easy
plt plot mean
mean okay let's see
if it works okay this is the mean of the
means value
and i will plot this before
just not to hide this line after i will
use fill between
okay what does this function mean it
needs
x values so i will create them
from one to 366 okay this will
give me a 365 values
from 1 to 365.
so there is and now i want
max max you mean
me oh sorry i mean mean
okay there i have it we can see we have
some wrong data here
this is a data from 2004 i think
it was and have some zeros in the
minimum temperature for
this should be august or something like
that which is obviously wrong but
i didn't trick this one so
okay and now i will
end with this and let my colleague zero
to finish with
some of the things he had let's compare
just the
2015 against the mean of the mean values
of the last 12 years which we can do
with
plt plot days
uh temp data sorry
and data tube okay
i want everything
i want only the
mean which is the first one and
i want the last one which is 2015.
that's 2015 and now if i do the same
well if i copy the mean of the means
well i didn't know that
okay here we can see if 2015 was
hotter in summer than the mean of the
means
which it was we had also some cold days
here
and the last thing i was going to do was
to plot the same
field between with 2015 and the mean of
the mean max of the max
but we are running out of time and i
think it's better if we continue with
some other packages
that made that might be interesting for
you so zero
okay uh so now we're going to
paint with colors because that's uh the
whole point of the workshop
paint with colors as the fun part so the
first thing we're going to do is create
a function
of two variables and then paint it
where we can use any numpy function we
will use
an empire eyes in order to do this so
let's just print any function we want
like for example np dot
cos x
times np dot
cos y because why not
so yeah for example that's a function
that will do it
so uh let's try if it works in zero d
like one point
yeah i think so let's see if works
in one dimension so
as always if we want to see the hub just
shift tab to see what we have to do so
plt.plot we need x and y
so x we can make like
np dot how was called a function of
numpy in order to get like a
distribution a uniform distribution of
numbers do you remember lines
faith i was asking for like uh yeah not
a random distribution but just
like a series of numbers ordered you
know what
okay so uh line space just i will answer
myself
line space you were right but
i was talking about another thing uh
line space we will create
like an array of numbers
from i don't know um 0
to 10 because okay then it's a nice
number i like them with like for example
100 numbers yeah that's i think it's
cool and uh well
i will just copy and cut and paste
this from here to
here because i called
this x and
our y will be the
uh function of
this okay so for example a function
requires
a key here function requires
x and y so x will will be x
x and
for example a number will do the magic
for example 10
or 0 or 1 or whatever and i just
write this stupid nonsense here which
doesn't mean anything
so now we have okay so our function
works in 1d but
let's go to the fun part which is
obviously
create a plot of 2d functions which is
very nice because has a lot of colors
and colors are always nice
but we need to create a grid okay in
order to plot
our 2d dimension uh plots we will need
to create a grid
over which we will plot the surface okay
so we will have
a grid in x and y direction and then
plot
like the sera dimension over there okay
like a surface like a 3d surface
so first uh we will create
the matrix x and y okay so we
first create the one the arrays we need
so for example from 0 to 5 and from
minus 2 to 4 because
it's okay they will make nice numbers
and we will use a new function called
mesh grid
in order to uh fuse their two
vectors together in order to get
matrices okay because we will need
uh the the x and y position of
each point of the grid in form of two
matrix
a matrix of x coordinates and a matrix
of
y-coordinates
implemented
uh
okay maybe if we were not of time i will
switch to the complete notebook
so we will just execute and see what
happened because the colors are what
is important not me talking so misgrid
um okay help me what we need
just the two vectors so x
slash that thing y
blah okay if you do just
uh you stop it will try to auto complete
what
what you're uh writing so it's very nice
so let's see uh what is the aspect of
the x-ray
as you see it's a matrix in which
each cell of the matrix has the value of
the x
coordinate of that point okay so
that's the aspect and the
y matrix has itself
the y coordinate of that point
now we will create the sera
coordinate of each point using the
function
we will use numpy arrays because that
will make
our life easy now because if we use like
the normal
python we will have to make like two
loops
one inside the other in order to go
each point but that's uh that's very
long so we will use
numpy and make it easy so said it's like
function of what
x and y and that's it that's it
it's like already done okay
let's plot it that's the fun part let's
get colors that's the main point of the
talk
so we will use a new function that it's
contour okay uh which means
a print lines it will uh
interpret the three matrixes as a
set of coordinates x y and z and try to
make like
a line of levels i don't know linear
denim well i don't know
the english translation for
contour lines okay so it was easy from
the beginning okay sorry
so contour lines uh what we need we need
um well i think i remember x
y and z and that other order and then we
will need to
uh specify which levels we are going to
plot
and we can do it like for example 0
1 2 why not let's try it and that's not
very nice
because we're plotting some values that
doesn't really mean something in this
function but we can make like
np dot linspace
what that's not no that's an mp
because otherwise it wouldn't work lean
space
so from like minus one
to one and for example seven values
let's try with this
we will get this ugly picture because we
use like a very very low resolution for
our mattresses
so let's just do it again okay
um linspace
lin space what
okay 10 minutes and
lin space
what's here
what okay okay so i know that's
mesh grid sorry that's not right here
we will use this
here okay here we have to use
this and okay now we have a nice graph
so uh we can use it to plot
uh also the the colors
with this other function like
the previous one was conto this one is
contour
f with f from fill like fill the gaps
with colors we can make it look like
more smooth if we use
more points here remember
when i selected here seven
okay if i select like 100
i will get like something better this is
contour let's try contour
f
okay so we have like these nice colors
okay and blah blah we can
print this beautiful things and
um okay always analyze data
please this is a nice
thing i say to you always visualize data
please always
always visualize that that's
uh the gravitational wave from the
lego okay that's the real data i just
use it because i think it was a nice
example of data that must be visualized
here that it's the the signal of two
emerging
black holes which is [ __ ] awesome so
if you plot it like in detail it will
lag
like that island of frequencies
and widgets that's awesome widgets is
like
a very very nice thing we have with the
notebook
okay we have to import it and we will
try
a little example uh function in order to
see
what happens if we use it okay
so we will use the interact function we
just
imported and
uh the first
argument we have to pass is the function
we want to interact to
uh gameplay
and x
equal equal 10 for example this will
give you
uh the this is slider
so here we have example x
print x so we have here
x and we can slide this
okay so the function will respond
to the input we make through the slider
which is awesome really
this this is great if we had for example
a variable
string like hello so
we can do the same thing so we have not
in a slider here but
a box uh text box so we can just
encoding and the
the answer will change accordingly
and if we use like
a list of things for example
this one it will give us this nice
selector okay
we can control the sliders uh with more
precision which i will show you later
and we can have if we have uh
a dictionary we can make this look
very nice you have all of this in the
complete version of the notebook
if you want to see it later because we
are like running out of time i'm very
sorry for running like this
but just we will go to the nice nice
thing
okay do you know um aem modulation for
sinus
like the radio waves and that kind of
things
that looks cool like we have an audio
signal
we want to send we have a radio signal
which we will use to send it
and we want like to combine the two in
order to send it to
whoever is listening to us
so we will have like this kind of
function
right okay we can do it with uh numpy
and matlib and now with the
widgets we can interact with this
so i have to like write
uh everything so i will if you forgive
me i will just
switch to the complete version because i
have already all written here
and it will be easier for both of us
to follow it if it's already written and
i don't have to write everything again
because we're running out of time so if
it will please
load thank you okay so
okay okay i was like
here okay if you select
a cell and press a from
the word above we can create a new cell
above
so let's import
by snp
matplotlib inline
import mat plot leap
dot pi plot
as multi and
from it
import interact
okay and we have
this thing which i think it's pretty
awesome if you want to
like quickly uh develop
or test your functions like we want to
change
the frequency in real time and see what
happens
i mean this is i like this a lot okay
it i find it really interesting
see you can do it in your notebooks
it's okay i won't play around with this
any
more time because it's awesome but yeah
okay now you know it
and i will spend the two minutes that i
have left
explaining another package with i think
it's
pretty awesome as well which is simpai
which come from symbolic python uh
i don't know if you know what that means
that means we will not work anymore
with numbers within pi like our
floating dots numbers this will use
symbols and solve things symbolically
okay
first we have to like import it
and activate it
and let's try the basic unit
of simpay it's the symbol object
which has like this ending
you will use to call the object and
has a graphical symbol which in this
case
is c sub t
we can create uh
symbols with greek leaders which
are nice because in mathematics and
physics we use a lot of greek
letters because greek letters looks
awesome and we we can see what
assumptions are made for each
symbol when we create them for example
it's a real number
it's it doesn't have any imaginary part
because here we have specified that it's
real
this is important because when we later
use them
we can have word properties from
logarithms or exponentials like
imaginary parts unexpected so
when we put together uh
symbols we can create expressions that
we can
later call for example expert
here we have an expression object which
contains this
expression that for example we can
interact with them for example
if we want to simplify it's one because
that's a mathematical property of
of numbers that sinus
square plus casinos square is one so it
will detect it
and simplify if we want it we can
substitute
one for example x from with
a y squared and the expression will
change
we can particularize and we will get the
results
uh symbolically this is not
a real number but we can get the real
number
using this function eval
okay so we can use um the precision we
want here specify
okay we can manipulate them for example
this nice expression we can
expand it in order to change from this
form to this other form
if we want to because we need it or for
example
we can uh differ
um derivate it
okay differ differentiate it i don't i'm
sorry i don't really know the english
word for that
or differentiate
if we have expressions with two
variables
we can uh differentiate
it from the using the the
variable we want it we can inter
integrate okay
i don't know if this makes you pay
attention because
it's integrating symbolically which is
like
i didn't know that machines can't do
this okay that's
it's awesome i think skynet will be born
from a notebook from
okay so we can integrate this uh and use
like this symbols as parameters and
don't lose it
it's okay i mean that's that blew my
mind when i
learned this we can solve equations for
example this equation we can solve them
okay and it's solved it's well
we can solve differential question it's
like
this is some kind of weird magic i don't
really understand
so okay so we're going to
end here and just talk
okay pandas we will learn later with
kiko
psychic learn we will not learn here
because there will be plenty of talks
and workshops about psychic learn
because it's the main package
for machine learning and data science
and okay that's all
so uh if you have any question alex and
i
will be happy
okay so any questions sorry for running
so fast at the end
okay so he's asking if i can use the
widgets
outside the notebook but in the plot
itself i think for example
okay um as as long as i know
no because the ipython widgets are like
a development for the notebook but i
think there are
other ways to interact with a map lovely
plot which are from matplotlib itself
not the ipython widgets kiko knows
very well everything about
ipython box
so you will work with
more or less
is
okay so uh more questions
i have a question how many people here
for example
enough for an answer
hello
okay do you want the coffee news
it's okay sorry because we are very
crowded today
sorry about that we have some
issues with this so please sorry it's
our fault
later please
so coffee is that you want thank you
thank you